[Music]
the big news in bachelor nation the
controversial Corinne is coming back to
paradise for the reunion show I've
considered Kareena friend I'm glad but I
don't have any opinions on it because it
shouldn't really a good friend I know
that I may not be everyone's favorite
person yeah I consider her a friend you
know I would tell you I really do like
her oh my god
Corinne tells et quote I am very happy
to be appearing on The Bachelor in
Paradise special but some cast members
told et on lines lauren zima
they're not as sight one told me that
currents return is a quote total
surprise
while another says that reactions are
kind of a mixed bag quote we'll have to
hear her side of things yes who else
will be back Demario you'll remember
that their pool hookup led to an
investigation into allegations of
misconduct and even a temporary shutdown
in production now at the time Corinne
called herself a victim but ultimately
Demario was cleared and production
resumed shooting just without the two
events season four will now premiere on
August 14th but could it feature footage
of Corinne and de Mario's interactions
ABC wouldn't confirm but we're told when
filming resumed on this series producers
did encourage the cast to talk about
what happened a source says that when it
comes to the cast sentiments quote
certainly no one is blaming jamario so
where is de Mario well he's in Europe
but the booted Bachelorette contestant
will be back in LA by next Friday to
tape the men tell all special and rachel
is ready I need someone who owns their
mistake when they're presented to them
if he has anything to say I'll listen
but I said my piece and then you said
peace thank you I like that lady very
very much now I cannot wait to hear what
new mario has to say when the men tell
all that's gonna air on July 31st on ABC
[Music]
you